welcome everyone
thank you for joining us today for our
presentation titled
analyzing monoclonal antibiotic
glycosylation at multiple levels
using the 6545xp advanced bio
lc qtof it's my pleasure to introduce
today's speaker
speaker dr david wong senior application
scientist for lc ms solutions at agilent
technologies
for a complete biography on our speaker
you may visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will be addressing all of
the questions submitted following this
presentation
so right now please join me in welcoming
dr wong i will now turn the presentation
over to him
hello everyone thanks again to this
laplace glycan symposium
my name is david wong and i'm a vacation
scientist at agilent
focusing on the biopharma application
development
in this presentation i would like to
give a short introduction
on how agilent is focusing on providing
an
end-to-end solution from the sample prep
to data analysis for several
biopharmaceutical workflows
we have developed four major level of
the glycan
or glycoform relative quantitative
analysis
workflow each workflow requires varying
degree
of sample preparation data acquisition
as well as the data processing method
as the result you get a different type
of information from the different floor
now i would like to talk about events
that we have made in each of this
workflow
for glycoform or glican relative
quantitative analysis
designing an instrument and consumable
that work together
seamlessly across the entire workflow
allow us to design and deliver
complete and efficient solution for the
biopharmaceutical
application we have developed a complete
solution
from the sample prep and the sample
separation
sample detection to data processing
for all the major biopharma workflow
such as the intact antibody analysis
antibodies subunit analysis and the body
peptide mapping or release glycan
analysis
in the sample prep area we have the asmr
power liquid handling platform
which simplify the sample preparation
allows high throughput and provide
excellent reproducibility
you can use the smart browser to purify
sample
using the different type of cartridges
such as the protein a
or protein g for antibody c18 for
protein digest
titanium dioxide for phosphorus peptide
enrichment
for the sample separation agilent 1290
infinity 2
uh plc is an ideal system
with a full selection of advanced bio lc
columns for all major workflows
we also have a 2d lc with a multiple
head cutting technology available
if you have a complex sample or want to
increase the sample
separation power in the ohmic analysis
while we are focusing on the liquid
chromatography i do want to mention that
the agilent 7100 capri electrophoresis
system is fully supported with the 6545
xt
advanced bio lcq top system for
completely
completely integrated cems interface
the new 6545 xt advanced by
lcq top has a unique feature that
enhance the
usability for the analysis of antibody
and many other biomolecules
the spectral quality of the large
molecule
like antibody have been improved
drastically
mainly due to the improve in the top
vacuum
also a greater than four times increase
in signal
or sensitivity or was achieved using the
large molecules from autotune
this improvement allows for more
confident
identification of the low level isoform
in the sample
the 6545 kilotop system can also be used
for routine peptide mapping
and whole cells protein identification
with the new uterus
msms data acquisition program
the mass hunter bioconfirm 10.0
is a one-stop protein analysis software
that support all major biopharma
workflow data analysis
from the intact antibody intake mass
deconvolution
glycoformulated quantitative analysis
peptide mapping protein sequence
coverage
to glycan profiling
now let's talk about the intake antibody
glycoform
characterization workflow how you
prepared an
intact protein has a lot of the impact
on the information you get sample
preparation plays a key role in the
final accuracy
and sensitivity when analyzing protein
importantly the intake protein can be
prepared
a variety of ways to get access of the
in different information about the
molecule
the sme bravo system provides a simple
user interface to perform protein
purification
as well as other protein manipulations
since every protein behaves differently
we have the portfolio of anabolic
excellence by
lc column available offering a range of
different separation cap
capabilities we have particular
had good success for rapid separation of
the intake antibody
as well as the reduced light and heavy
change of
the subunit using this plrps
one one thousand ancient column
the 6545 advanced bio lcq top
has a servo feature and design element
that directly benefit to the intact
protein
analysis now let's talk about these
features
the intel protein data quality that is
produced by the 6545
xt is incredibly detailed and accurate
this is due to the improve of the vacuum
design
and reduce the flight to pressures
almost an order of magnitude better
than other time of flight system
we have also developed a new tuning
algorithm
to specifically optimize the entire
system
for analysis of very large molecule when
you needed to
this is the next advanced advancement of
the
agilent's swarm auto tune in order to
accommodate the system performance to
your applications
the improved spectrum quality and large
molecule twins
has greatly improved our large molecule
transmission in the mass spec
now since we can see a higher ammo c ion
we extended the mass range all the way
up to 30 000
mm overz
lastly we have include a gate vial
in the front end of the optic then
that allow us to seal the manifold
and remove the sampling category from
basic maintenance
so you don't have to vend the system uh
and then later on pump it down so that
means
you have less time waiting for the
system
to be ready and you have more time to
running sample
in the mass spec data analysis
analysis area the mass hunter about
confirm is our software program
dedicated to biologic
analysis so this is a very powerful tool
that can be set up to analyze your data
automatically as the sample is finishing
acquiring you have the option to have it
automatically been processed by
bioconfirm
which means that integrating the
chromatography peak
and extracting the protein spectra
deconvoluting the spectrum to get the
intact protein mass
and matching those methods to your
predicted
or expected sequence
so this the user interface of for the
mass hunter balcon firm
when you are wheeling the intake protein
data
the protein sample that you have opened
up
in is in the table area
on the top um the data was automatically
processed
and then now it's been reviewed the
chromatogram
was integrated and the
mass spectrum extracted from the peak
showing on the left side so
now the raw protein spectrum was
deconvoluted
to a zero charge mass spectrum that
showed in the middle here
and each pig farm in that decommulative
spectrum
showed up as an entry in the biomolecule
table at the
bottom here the table
now with the proposed modification such
as the glycoform
and the mass shift all the detailed
information
is in the table here so additionally
so each biomolecule can be attracted
to wheel where the where they form
is shown up in the chromatography run
file confirm software program also allow
user
to compare a specific biomolecule
for example the g1f plus g1f glycoform
between multiple samples or even a batch
samples
once the biomolecule is selected for
comparison
a filter will be set up and other
information will be filtered out
in the biomolecule table
so this is the results on the intact
mixed antibody glycoform
relative quantitative analysis
10 replicate injection were run
and the bar chart showing that similar
results
integrated by either the peak high or by
peak area and they are all with a good
isd value
the main major advantage of this intake
and the body workflow is that
it enable customer to gain rapid
assessment
of the major glycoform of the intake
in their body each sample one is only
four minutes
however each glycophone peak represents
a combination of
two glycan from both sides of the heavy
chains
so therefore additional calculation is
needed to figure out the true
value of those individual glycan for
example
g0f g1f or g 2 f
we have also developed a geiger form
quantitative analysis workflow
at the antibodies subunit especially
the heavy change level
again very similar left setup is needed
for this workflow
you need the sms bravo system
agilent's 1290 infiniti 2 usplc
with the porp column the 6545xt
advanced bio lcq top and the bioconfirm
10.0 software
in this workflow one can either perform
a full reduction of the intake antibody
and then turn it into a heavy or light
change of
subunits or
you can perform the idex enzymatic
digestion first
and the follow by the reduction to
generate
the fc molecule which have the glycan
steel attached
so in both case they are building
protocol
in the snmp bravo system to perform this
step we have also published a couple of
the app notes
covering this application area
this is the total ion chromatogram and
the
uh decommorating mass spectrum of the
nist anabolic subunit
a porps column was used in this
workflow so as you can see excellence
liquid chromatography separation of the
lighting and heavy change was
achieved using the very short hplc
gradient
and so in the left panel here so under
the
heavy chains uh peak area
so p three major glycophone uh g1
g0f1 g1f and g2f was observed
and the relative quantitation abundance
was calculated so it's also worth to
mention that
a full reduction on that nissan double d
sample is required
to reduce the heterogeneity of the heavy
chains
and to obtain accurate quantitative
information
so the as you can see here
the average percent of a quantitation
value of
the free geico form uh from
10 technical replicate which was
calculated and show
it as uh 39
of 48 and 13
the average standard deviation of this
results was
less than 0.3
now let's look at the glycopeptide
workflow for glycan
relative corona analysis
the smf bravo system was also used
for antibody purification
proteolytic digestion and sample cleanup
the digest sample was then run on to
both the agilent's advanced bio peptide
mapping
which is this reverse phase c18 column
and also the advanced bio glycan mapping
column which is the
helix column for compression
so under the routine reverse phase hplc
condition
peptides are separated by their
hydrophobicity
but the glycopeptides are more
hydrophilic
so it has a short retention time on the
reverse phase column
it would just enlarge in the first
couple of minutes
however the helix column is the
orthogonal
method to the reverse phase column so
where the hplc gradient is
reversed high resolution
in the separation was achieved for
glycopeptide
and as you can see all the major
glycopeptides
were eluded between 28 to
34 minutes
the relative quantitation on all
identified peptide
including the glycopeptide was also
automatically calculated
using either the peak high or peak area
of the mass spectrum
one feature of the bioconform 10.0
software
is that users have the ability to select
or deselect
a certain peptide for grouping in the
relative quantitation analysis
in the reverse phase separation a set of
free glycol
peptides with the sequence of eeq
starting eeq or the six glycopeptide
with a sequence studying that pk tkpr
was identified but however
in the reverse phase
method the same group of
glycopeptide were co-eluding so it's
poor
chromatography resolution i was observed
so on the other hand when we use the
helix
column for separation a great resolution
for the separation of the same set of
the glycopeptide
was achieved as shown in this slide
the full gei-ken relative coin analysis
workflow is on the instant pc label
release glidecam sample
in this workflow the sma bravo liquid
handling system
with a geico prep plus rapid and guy can
sample preparation kit with the instant
pc label
uh from the pulsar was used though
the total sample prep time it was
about two to three hours
so this the represented representative
chromatogram of the anglican
from the knees and the body we have the
force and data as well as the mass spec
theta so the frozen chromatogram on the
top panel
revealed that more than 15 glycogen
peaks
were detected the guy constellation
pattern
of the major abundance of skycam such as
the
c0f 211
g1f glycoform or g2f
was comparable between this foursome
and also the massback data
the personal compound database the pcbl
library containing the accurate mass and
the structural information of this
glycan
is used for identification using the
agilent's proprietary fiber formula
algorithm the relative sum
abundances of the top seven most
abundance and end guide king was
calculated
and compared from the
ms analysis
so here are the relative connotation
results comparison
uh from the all four level of the
glycoform or glycan workflow
on three major glycan molecule
the g0f g1f and g2f
as you can see this results are quite
con
consistent with each other within just a
few percentage
so in conclusion we have developed a
complete and efficient
workflow solution for antibody glycoform
characterization
by integrating uh the agilent's sme
bravo
liquid handling platform for the sample
pep
the uh plc technology
for the separation and agilent 6545 xt
advanced bio lcq tough system for the
detection
and the azurance masshundra bioconfirm
software for data analysis
so this is a pose or for user flexible
workflows for glycan relative
connotation
at a different analytical level
so in the intact inner body workflow
provides a rapid assessment for the
major clinical form of the entire
antibody
and the antibodies of unit workflow
offer detailed quantitative information
about
the individual guidelines such as
0f g1f and g2f
the glycopeptide workflow shows the
result not only
in the glycan related quantitation
but also uh can be identified
and glycosis glycosylation site
the release glycan workflow provides
higher
analytical sensitivity and the best
quantitation
for the glycan analysis using both
forcing on the mass spec data
so with this i want to thank you for
your time
and attentions
that was great thank you dr wong for
that outstanding presentation
we're now going to move into the live q
a portion
as a reminder you can still submit any
questions you have in the
q a box so our first question
is how much antibody do you need
for the intact monoclonal antibody and
monocle
antibody subunit glycoform analysis
workflows
i normally use about 0.5 to 1 microgram
per
injections so even though our mass back
system can detect much
lower amount of antibody but this
injection amount give us the more
reliable result on the quantitation
analysis
okay all right next
can you use the bioconfirm released
glycan software with a different sample
prep or lc system
i think you mean whether we can use
confirm to analyze that icon with a
different for syntax label
uh yes you can do that about confirm
allow
user to customize the labeling attack by
using either the mass of the the tag or
the chemical formula of the text
okay great next can
i perform the intact mass subunit
glycopeptide and released glycan
workflows
without the assaymap bravo system
yes of course but the manual sample prep
will take much longer time
and the reproducibility is kind of low
okay good to know um next
can you detect the minor glycoforms in
the intact
monoclonal antibody and monoclonal
antibodies subunit workflows
not really you we can detect some minor
glyco forms such as the g1 g0f plus g1f
minus
the correct net okay but to detect the
more guide cam it's better to run the
release skycam workflow
okay all right next
how much antibody do you need for the
released
glycan analysis workflow on the assay
map bravo
as described in our app notes the
end guy can experiment uh
injected at the freak release glycan
that is from about one to two microgram
of the intake and the body sample
okay and we have one final question that
was submitted
how long does the assay map release
glycan sample preparation take
if i remember correctly the whole sample
prep process time
was including the reagents
set up immobilization digestion
the instant pc labeling and also sample
cleanup
it takes about two to three hours uh the
detailed procedure
of that sample prep is described in the
application notebook provided by the
post sign
now but there's a newer sample
prep kit called the glidex with the
instant
diet that is available which it would
take less than
one hour in prep time
all right excellent well that is all the
questions that were submitted so thank
you again dr wong
and thank you to the audience for your
attendance and for
submitting your insightful questions we
hope you found today's presentation to
be informative
it will be available soon for on-demand
viewing
now don't miss out on the other valuable
presentations on our agenda
please visit the event presentation
schedule that can be found in the
auditorium
so until next time i hope you all have a
great day
thank you